when I saw you went and did the watch
site hodinki uh first of all Sean have
you ever read that like when I when I
heard I was like a Blog I like watches I
have Rolexes as like a Blog for luxury
watches what the hell is this guy
thinking did you did you just say that
it went from like a million or two in
revenue and now it's Sam said it's over
100 million yeah yeah we're over 100
million in Revenue now man that is why
it's insane
[Music]
laughs
what's up all right in this episode we
are sitting down with Kevin Rose uh a
lot of you know Kevin because he's an
internet OG he created dig back in the
day he was a seed investor in Twitter
and a bunch of other cool companies he
was been a he's been a VC he's been a
Founder he launched it recently launched
an nft project that's done hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of nft sales
and so um Kevin's has been around for a
while and the cool part of the interview
if you if you listen to it you're going
to see very chill guy very um down to
earth very humble and
um not a kind of like
oh my God I'm gonna go take over the
world you know bubbling over with
ambition and a big chip on his shoulder
seemed like a happy dude who was
enjoying himself and had a ton of
success in the process and I like that I
like seeing diff people who play the
game with different in different ways
and he's definitely somebody who's
interested we talked about
um a bunch of his projects that you may
not know about so for example is
creating watchville this Niche project
for watches That Grew From one million
in Revenue to now over 100 million after
it got Acquired and merged with hodinki
um then also we talked about how he
hires writers we talked about
um you know how he got into Twitter as
an early investor and what does he do
with his money so he's got a bunch of
money uh how does he invest it where
does he put it and uh the answer is not
not what you may have expected the last
thing we did at the end is we did the
crypto debate so Sam is sort of a uh a
crypto skeptic Kevin is obviously a
crypto believer and one of the kind of
most well-known guys in the crypto scene
and we had a little debate 8 where we
talked about is it all [__] or are
there some use cases so I hope you
enjoyed this episode with Kevin Rose
I liked it I think he will too
we should give like a brief overview
overview but like your resume we don't
really talk too much about like resumes
and stuff but your resume is like crazy
long so I've been following you forever
uh so I've known about your work so you
started dig which was when did you start
that in 04 2004 that's right yeah and so
you were it was like one of the original
like site like link aggregators and it
was like a cultural phenomenon and that
was crazy and you were like was it Time
magazine that you were on the cover of
Like Your Business Week business week it
was like here's this young kid taking
over Silicon Valley what's the internet
and who's this kid controlling it type
of thing uh and like it had all this
hype but like dig didn't turn out maybe
as wonderful as like we we all thought
maybe it could have done but then you
like had your finger on the pulse of all
these other things you've done a dig you
done is it I read it all the time but is
it pronounced hodinki yeah oh dinky a
watch blog that also like sells watches
you're a partner at Google Ventures you
have this app called zero fasting that I
use I love partner at trueventures which
I still think you're at now you've got
the uh you got the uh the oak uh uh
meditation app and then I have a feeling
there's like five or ten other things
that you just have Brewing that like I
don't even know like most people
probably don't even know about but
you're basically my point is is like
you're kind of an Internet OG and you
are incredibly prolific I mean does that
kind of summarize it
yeah I mean the most recent thing I
started was proof which is our our
Venture into the world of nfts and so
that's that's the only thing uh missing
from from that and that that's about
um 10 months old now so
that's that's on the newer side so from
the outside if I look at this kind of
like collection of or like the career
path it looks very random it's like you
know from you know from venture-backed
to Angel vesting to venture investing to
kind of like Niche communities uh you
know these like kind of apps that are
like simple like like meditation or
fasting uh you did a podcast you did a
show you know you've done a bunch of
content you did a bunch of different
things was there a method to the madness
is this do you just describe it as
random or is there kind of like some
underlying theme to this whole thing
yeah there's I would say that I've
always been one yeah ever since I was a
little kid to just tinker and just to to
play and if there's any method to the
madness it is this common thread of
exploration and just wanting to if I see
something that doesn't exist that should
exist I want to go build it and I've
done that a handful of times
um you know probably
at least 10 to 15 businesses of which
you know 90 of them go to zero and then
there's a few that pop and become you
know pretty big so
um it's just this idea that uh I don't
want to sit on the sidelines if there's
something that's exciting that needs to
be built I I'd rather just spin up a
team and go after it
of all those projects and I'm actually
going to exclude proof from that because
uh I want to talk all about that in a
little while but of all those projects
that I mentioned which one has been the
most financially successful for you
personally
that's a good question
um certainly I would say
when I was in the middle of Web 2.0
which was the the when dig was at its
its peak which was
um about a 2000 early 2006
um you know we were hit around 38
million people a month using the site it
was you know of the web 2 properties it
was one of the largest
um it it led me to sitting down and you
know dinners and conversations and
hangouts with the You Know Jack dorsey's
and Evan Williams and zuckerbergs and
all the household names that became
these big products and they were just
friends and so because of that
um it was more like hey well you know do
you want to invest in my new thing and
and so I would say the investment side
has definitely been the the best
financial returns I did start a media
company
um that uh well I would say there's
there's two things that that well three
that are too unrealized in hodinki
um which is is is going to be crazy
it'll you know it's over 100 million
Revenue a year now which is nuts whoa
really um and then we have
um you know uh the stuff I'm doing a
proof right now which has just been
another crazy rocket ship but in terms
of like true exits of businesses that
I've started
um revision three uh where I was the
co-founder as a media company that
became um Discovery Channel's digital
arm and we sold that for 35 million
dollars back in uh
2008 or something like that so that was
probably the biggest company sale that
I've had
um but you know they're much larger on
the more Angel investment side and maybe
that sale gave you the the ammo to do
the angel of it to do Angel Investing or
would you have been able to do it
without it a bit but I was already
starting to
do small Investments uh prior to that so
I I didn't have any money I didn't come
from money
um but when dig really took off and we
were a couple years in to dig investors
and this is a very common practice it
doesn't get talked about a lot but
investors come around and they're like
hey you know you're doing this round of
financing can we take a little pressure
off of you as an entrepreneur and buy
some of your stock personally right and
so I sold a little bit of my dig stock
enough to give me the ammo to go and do
small C checks you know and put you know
25k into you know Twitter's seed round
and and put you know 25k and or it was
more into Facebook but
um they're a little bit later stage and
and so it was it was those little tiny
checks that you know when they turn into
multi-billion dollar businesses uh were
pretty meaningful how much does 25k into
Twitter and Facebook early on actually
turned into it at millions of dollars I
mean that that math is even hard to
comprehend and Twitter's seed round what
was evaluation then well it was
difficult because they were a podcast
company uh doing podcast software and
then they they did a new round they they
pivoted into Twitter and so oh gosh I'm
drawing a blank on the name of the
podcast audio that's right they were
audio
so
um yeah I didn't invest in audio they
had become Twitter and I asked EV who I
was the tightest with at the time
because I didn't really know Jack that
well at that yet and I asked to have a
huge CEO and I was like you know can I
can I invest and there was no round
available at that point they but he's
like I got this engineer that
um Blake that was leaving and had some
stock and was like do you just want to
buy some of the stock and I was like
yeah that sounds great I'll just buy
something I think Gary vaynerchuk said
the same story
yes yes so here's the funny thing yeah
so I bought in from Blake and then I I
told Gary that Blake was selling some
and
um then Twitter ended up actually they
had a preemptive round come along that
really like like five or ten extra
evaluation and then Blake was like oh
whoa well no there's a new valuation now
and he charged carry the new price so
Gary's still pissed at me because I got
this like really cheap price for Twitter
stock you know and then uh and then Gary
had to pay the more expensive price but
that was a funny little what do you
think Blake's saying right now I mean
Blake probably just he did he held on to
like half or more and so you know he
probably I don't know he if I had to
guess he made 50 plus 75 plus million
dollars or something on it he I'm sure
he's okay did uh at the time because
Twitter kind of had like a well there's
like audio kind of failing Twitter who
knows uh and then there was like this
like small community of people in
Silicon Valley that were like using it
back when it was like texting the the
your updates out
um like when you're when you were
writing that check did you feel like
this is the you know the next big thing
or was this kind of like I don't know my
friends are smart let's see or where was
it like it was the next big thing
because there was I I loved so
as someone that was building a social
graph of sorts at dig you know there was
always this idea back prior to um excuse
me prior to Twitter that was
um bi-directional friendships so you
know on MySpace you and Friendster and
all the others they did come prior to
Twitter you had to actually know the
person to see their content so it was
like I would you like to send a friend
request yes do you accept this friend
request yes right and it was like same
thing with Facebook and when Twitter
came out with that model of just this
idea of following
and and it allowed like there was no
celebrities on the platform it was like
me and Lee LaPorte and a couple others
that were the top followed people on the
platform at the time
um but I I thought to myself like wow if
this catches on with the celebrity crowd
it's just gonna be insane it's gonna be
because everyone will just want to see
and also the barrier to entry a lot of
back then it was it was um
it was impossible to get uh you know
celebrities to sit down and kind of um
do technical things because that we
didn't really have smartphones but the
fact that you could text to that number
that short code just what you were up to
anybody can do that it doesn't require
any special software it doesn't require
you sitting in front of a computer and
so it was just so dead simple to use it
felt as though as I saw the tech crowd
you know um kind of catching on uh it I
knew eventually it would spill outside
of that that small vertical of users
into the mainstream and if that when
that would happen that was the bet when
that would happen uh if and when that
would happen that would it would it
would blow up and and it did so that was
that was awesome and I remember I've
also seen uh you did a video back in the
day when Square was like a prototype it
was like a YouTube video I remember you
you're like hey yeah check this out like
you know here's this little square and
you could plug it into your phone you
could take credit card payments you're
like and it was not even released yet
and you were like you know promote I
think you did you invest in that too
because that would have been like yeah
so that's a great story because I hit
jack up and I was like hey I heard
you're doing this new credit card thing
I'd like to be an angel investor and
he's like oh dude it's over subscribed
I'm sorry like we've closed the round
like blah blah and I was like damn it
I'm like well let me see if I can help
you in some way and so he gave me a
prototype and
um I just went and recorded a video and
it got a lot of traction and it got a
lot of people excited about this new
product and it was like an early glimpse
of what was to come and it started
getting you know tens of thousands of
views on on YouTube and he calls me back
and he's like I had an investor drop out
I've got some room do you want to do you
want to put a check in and so that's
what got me into um to their seed round
which was which was awesome what was it
like uh you know I lived in San
Francisco from 2012 up until somewhat
recently Sean's still there it's
definitely a bit different now because
like startups are are quite popular and
and Jax and Jack Dorsey is like
basically a celebrity Mark Zucker was
obviously a celebrity
what was it when back then in uh the the
you know 040506 uh you know 2010 when
these things were just getting going
did you actually think that a guy like
Jack Dorsey was gonna be like this kind
of like Titan of of Industry like he
kind of is like what was it like being
around some of these folks early on when
they were just you know you guys were
just messing around well it was you met
a lot of entrepreneurs back then and
there was it was clear there was a few
people that stood out as just being
um wildly creative and and just deep
thinkers and I was really drawn to those
folks I wanted to just like pick their
brain more and get to know them better
and so you know
um
one of the things that struck me is just
how mature Mark Zuckerberg was when he
was younger like it was you know I'm
quite a bit older excuse me than he is
and um
how old is he now he's still only like
38. he's younger than that oh my God
yeah so how old is Mark that's oh yeah
you're right he's 38. yeah he's still
that's still I mean it is 30s that's
pretty wild yeah it it's it's it's crazy
um he was he was really young
um
so yeah so when I met him was
2005 I want to say so he was 21. wow so
he was 21 years old and I remember just
thinking about how put together he was
and how well spoken and just what a deep
thinker he was about the space and he
wasn't winging it he was taking it very
seriously and
um that was that was a big big shock to
me
um I remember just those conversations
being like I was like Wow for 21 I was
definitely not as put together as as he
was at 21. what's something he said that
made you made you think that
well you know one of the things that I
was always uh frightened by uh as an
entrepreneur in my in my youth was just
this idea of would people take me
seriously
um and could I admit when I didn't know
something and it was it was it okay to I
tried to hide my vulnerabilities as an
entrepreneur and he just came in and was
asking so many pointed questions and
um you know I asked him about some of
his hiring and firing practices and how
he would edit his team how he ensured
that he made the right hires on the
engineering side because it was it was
that was a very challenging thing to do
back then to scale websites you were
like racking your own servers and you
know it wasn't the aws's of the world
and we were talking a lot about that and
um it was just it was one of those
things where he just told me that
um he just you know it's obvious stuff
he's surround yourself with people
smarter than you and then you ask a lot
of questions and you're not afraid to
ask those questions so
um you know back then I had some great
investors and and board members but at
times I was a little hesitant to be like
hey I I don't quite understand how this
works can you help educate me and I
think it was due to my lack of like for
some reason I thought because I was a
College Dropout that I I had to hide
that and and they would be like if I
asked a question that I should have
learned in college that it would have
looked uh had it had egg on my face and
so there was a lot of um of of
nervousness around that and just to see
Mark just be so open and just curious
um and there was no it was clear that if
he if he didn't know something he was
going to get to the bottom of it right
away
um it was it was inspiring I had a I had
an experience just like that when we
were selling our last company
um I met with all the big companies
Facebook Google and Amazon whatever we
also met with Discord and I go in I meet
Jason who's the CEO of Discord and I'm
like pitching him on like you know
basically if you bought our thing like
it would add this Dimension to Discord
it would be awesome and what I was so
used to was most Founders if you if
you're just kind of saying how awesome
they are and how they can take over all
these different how there's so much more
they can do how this is just the
beginning and how there's all these
different ways that they can expand
normally they're like yes yes yeah yeah
totally we can do that too we can do
that too it all sounds good
and he was just sort of like
you know I would acquire you guys
because I like you and I like that you
came in and you had this like whiteboard
and you just like painted a picture for
me
um but we won't do any of that and he's
like um no that's not what Discord
should do what we should do and he said
no and he was like we should just be
this one horizontal utility that does
this one thing and um that's our that's
that's the right strategy for us and he
was the first guy that said no when I
was like kind of giving him some ice
cream of like you could have this too
right right and I just thought oh that's
what like this is this is probably what
Zuck was like you know this is probably
with somebody who was focused was like
because back when Zuck was building
Facebook it was like Myspace was adding
music and then TV shows and doing these
like brand deals and like he was just
like nope real names simple profiles
we're just gonna let you like you know
communicate and add photos and do this
stuff and like he said no to a bunch of
different things which is why Facebook
was some such a cleaner sight than
Myspace and all the other competitors
that were out there
yeah I would argue they've lost a lot of
that because they say yes to a lot of
the cloning of features of other other
competitors but yeah you're right that
Relentless
um focus is is so essential and
oftentimes it's it's more what you say
no to than what you say yes to on the
product side you know I I that totally
agrees and Vibes with me for sure do you
sort of uh when you're doing all these
projects uh back to the project do you
have like a set of rules like for
example I know a guy who is incredibly
successful
um I talked to him one time his name is
Kevin or a couple times his name is
Kevin Ryan he started like mongodb
Business Insider Guild group all these
like amazing companies and he was like
well I just do back of the envelope math
and then I give each project six months
and me and my partner typically fund it
with three hundred thousand dollars and
we kind of like feel it out it's a
little mathematical but it's also like
let's just see what happens in six
months and see if this is promising and
we'll decide uh and so he's like six
months 300K can we make something cool
and I talked to Atomic Labs the other
day you know Atomic Labs they're like
that incubator that's they're not really
an incubator they like start companies
and they said something like they're
like yeah well like sometimes we'll only
spend 50 Grand and like two months or
something like that do you have uh like
something like that when you're starting
a bunch of your projects like the
fasting app or the meditation app where
you're like I think you did another one
milk or is that the name of the
production yeah that was the name of the
the kind of incubator Studio yeah
yeah do you like have like rules for
what you're looking for
yeah I mean it's there is um I guess the
question really comes to when you decide
to kill something or sell it off or get
rid of it or move on to the next thing
and and oftentimes it's
um because your original kind of thesis
around either the market size or just
the concept behind it just didn't take
hold and so I don't have any like hard
set number of months sometimes you're
early so you know uh the fasting app for
example
um you know when I launched xero it's
sad at you know tens of thousands of
users for the first eight months
and then fasting hit and it became more
of a household thing and people were
talking about intermittent fasting it
was all over TV and different you know
places were picking it up and so people
were just naturally searching for
fasting in the app store because that's
just what they do and then that's when
it exploded to you know hundreds of
thousands and you know a million plus
monthly active people doing fast
um and but it was it had I shut that
down after the first six months
um you know it would have been too soon
so something like that if you if you
just believe the market is not quite
mature enough I typically put it into a
little bit more of a maintenance mode
you know I got it to that first version
where I felt like this is a useful
utility for people that are looking to
learn more and get into fasting
um now let's just uh let it kind of
organically build from here and we were
seeing you know nice slow consistent
kind of week over week month over month
growth but nothing explosive like you
you're used to seeing in a in a high
growth startup so
um if that one that one in particular
was just like let's just just wait
around and then other times you know you
create something and you've just clearly
missed the Mark it's it's like we
created this app called tiny which was a
fun little photo sharing app that was
um yeah I liked it oh you did awesome
yeah it was these little little
size uh looping videos with no audio and
we thought it would just be like a
little bit more quick a little intimate
way to show kind of how you're
traversing throughout your days and
weeks rather than having to take the
time to set up to look all perfect in
front of your perfect Instagram there
was less pressure literally because it
was small right exactly that part was
actually kind of true yeah and and that
was a crazy one because you know we
launched and it just it caught fire
immediately and we had you know hundreds
of thousands of downloads in the first
week and then it just died off
completely and everyone was like ah that
was a fad that was a that was a fun
little fad and that one we shut down
pretty quickly after that because it was
clear that it was a fun little thing but
but there was no depth to it it was a it
was a feature not not a real product so
um yeah it varies from product to
product I guess the best answer I can
give you cool
um okay so uh you talked a little bit
about like you know which one was the
most lucrative okay yeah obviously Angel
Investing in Twitter and then getting
into you know Facebook and others is
it works out well which one was the most
fun so which chapter uh was the most fun
and kind of with that is I'm on this
Mission I just you know like after
selling companies like I got time and so
I was like all right well what's the
party now I was like I want to find out
who's having the most fun in their
career and like because that's what I
want to do now I just have the most most
fun type of crew who's having the most
fun with their life right now so I want
to know for you which of your projects
the most fun and then who do you see who
who's a blueprint I could look at where
you're like this I met this person
they're having a blast with what they do
yeah well I would say that
the you know there's the nice thing
about starting your own businesses is
you're you're doing it because there's a
personal Drive behind it like I've never
created anything because I thought
here's an opportunity to make money it's
never been that it's it we were talking
about this as we were just you know
prior to hitting record or whatever
about the little podcast case holder on
Amazon right and like there's there's
there's sometimes there's these little
businesses where you see a broken piece
of an industry and you're like well gosh
if I went out and created this I could
sell X number of units per year and it'd
be a great little profitable business
and like that's never really interest me
it's more about the this the creativity
of it all and just the exploration of an
idea that I'm drawn to and so I I no
startup is fun they're they're all
they're all roller coasters
loop-de-loops like there's the chaos of
all those things right especially as you
grow your team and there's HR issues and
people getting sick and products not
getting shipped on time and customers
being upset and you know that there's
there's it's never going to be just like
this perfect dream but
um that said as long as it's something
that you're just naturally drawn to I'm
always having a good time and and I'd
I'd say though that said that's kind of
a you know a little bit of a dodging the
question but
um more recently when I've got it gotten
into the art in nft side of things uh
that world in the world of
cryptocurrency is probably the most fun
because it is so blue ocean and there's
just so much to be built there it's not
building yet another app and competing
on on CAC in the App Store it's like
it's it's really
um there's there's so many different
directions you can go
um and and very few well there there's
there is a decent amount of of high
quality entrepreneurs in the space but
not as as much as say you know building
something for the App Store so I enjoy
kind of more the blue ocean aspect of
that world man and I remember when so
basically I started this company called
The Hustle it was like a daily email and
we sold it for we bootstrapped and sold
it for tens of millions of dollars it
kind of It kind of sounds a little bit
similar to what you were saying about
your story I lived in San Francisco and
I started a media company because I was
like I'm not capable of starting a tech
company but I wish I were and also I'm
good at writing when I saw you went and
did the watch site uh hodinki uh first
of all Sean have you ever read that like
when I when I heard I was like a Blog I
like watches I have Rolexes as like a
Blog for luxury watches what the hell is
this guy thinking like he just like he
he he like it started as something else
right you started it as like watchville
or it was like a it was something else
you got acquired or merged and you
became like the CEO of this I remember
looking at that just being like I have
no idea what the hell he's doing I don't
wear watches so I had no I was
completely out of touch with it and it
just seemed like you know a hobby
project at the time and then I started
looking into it and I was like oh wow
there's like a huge passionate base
around this and this company makes a lot
of money then has been around I don't
think in time I don't think it did make
a lot of money did it like I remember I
read that and I was like I like this
business because I'm into it but like
this guy's frankly way above this what
is he thinking like this is he's like
this thing's needlessly hard well watch
Phil was so I again like just kind of
like personal passion stuff so I was
into watches mainly because when my
father passed away he left me with a
single watch and it's something that I
wear every once in a while and it was
for him it was like to afford a single
Rolex in a in a middle class household
is a big deal like that's like back in
the 80s you know when my dad bought that
he was just like I've made it you know I
have it and I'm not talking about one of
the crazy relaxes I'm talking about just
the standard day-date kind of like you
know simple relaxing like that was like
the one thing he was really proud of you
know that is like GMC pickup truck right
and so
um those that was something I was left
with and then I started reading uh some
of the content so Ben climber created
hodinki the actual blog and I created
Watch Phil which was an aggregator in an
app that brought together all these
different sources so that people could
read this stuff on the mobile on their
mobile phone because a lot of as silly
as it sounds back then most of the
excuse me most of the watch sites didn't
have mobile versions of their site so
they were on just like old old software
publishing software that what that was
just horrible so I I I made it all very
readable push notifications like all the
stuff just a kind of a wrapper for like
all this great content and it just
started growing and growing and growing
and I had a lot of eyeballs like some of
the the biggest collectors were Now
using the product and
um you know I I hodinki was the most
kind of best prominent source of this
content that took it very seriously so
it was um you know they had had a couple
full-time writers and so I talked to Ben
and said hey you don't have the tech
team here let's let's merge and combine
forces so
we um we merged the two companies
together
um he was three or four people and I was
three or four people
um I moved to New York became CEO at the
time he was doing uh maybe a million and
a half to two million dollars a year in
Revenue so just enough to kind of do
payroll and
um we grew it from there and then turned
on e-commerce and then started selling
uh and creating Partnerships with the
big watch brands and now you know as
authorized dealers represent you know
several dozen of the big watch brands
that are out there and that just became
a massive
um it was still a relatively unknown
back then whether or not people would
actually spend large sums of money over
Apple pay right and so
um I remember we had someone from Apple
that was
um you know helping us on when you get
to a certain size they kind of give you
a little bit more concierge help on the
apps stuff and they said that they had
seen their a 250 000 transaction action
come through Apple pay on an American
Express and that was like the largest
known transaction at that time that had
been done over Apple pay for a site
unseen uh vintage Rolex which was uh
which was kind of crazy but anyway yeah
so that I mean
new new luxury watches or double-digit
billions of dollars in a year
um in terms of Market size so it's it's
a big industry that that many people uh
it's not as apparent in the states uh
when you go overseas uh it you'll see
how in in Europe there you know watches
are so much more uh kind of a a type of
thing that is is worn versus smart
watches or more of the normal no watch
at all uh here in the states did you did
you just say that it went from like a
million or two in revenue and now it's
Sam said it's over a hundred million
yeah yeah we're over 100 million in
Revenue now man that is why that's
insane and a lot of it's Commerce I mean
you guys like
when people talk about content and
commerce I think most of the time it's
nonsense like BuzzFeed talks about it
and I'm like I don't know man I don't
think people are going to be buying a
lot of branded BuzzFeed pillows and [__]
like that or like they had that tasty
thing I was like I don't think people
are gonna buy a buzzfeed of it I just
don't think that's gonna happen and you
guys did it and I was like I don't know
is this like gonna be a thing it seems
so challenging but you guys are a
perfect example of that and you know the
other good example I bet you go to bring
a trailer do you go to bringatrailer.com
I've been to bring a trailer many times
yeah
it's one of his favorite sites actually
they are awesome and so they've done the
same thing but with cars where basically
it's like this perfect tie of like I
just I I bought one car from actually uh
those websites and um but I read it
every single day I'm like let's just see
like what they're gonna write about what
cool cars out there and then you guys
did it with watches and I loved your
videos with John Mayer where he talks
about his watch collection and all that
[__] it's awesome but what um what other
verticals or what other like Industries
have you thought man maybe I could
actually do this model I've always
thought software but like that's not
nearly as sexy and cool as Watchers in
vintage cars but is there any it's like
when you were like thinking about this
model I I bet you're at night you're
like I'm not gonna do it but I bet you I
could apply this here here and here
yeah I mean in some sense that's kind of
what we're doing right now in the world
of nfts where they're everyone that's
armed with Photoshop can create a
digital
um piece of art on the blockchain and
there's this mad rush into the world of
nfts but there is just a ton of clutter
right and and just a ton of of of of
projects to sort through so what we
created with proof was this this idea of
you know it's the same thing with
hodinki it's the same Playbook it's this
curation with a point of view where you
can have a strong editorial team come in
um that isn't talking about the flipping
side of the industry that isn't talking
about how to make a quick buck in nfts
that is really talking about what would
you buy and hold for the next decade
plus right and the Playbook that that
hodinki nailed so well was that we took
editorials so seriously and really hired
out just a absolute Stellar team of
writers that had a deep understanding of
the World of Watches and not just a
announcement this is a new watch that
was dropped but an understanding of the
the mechanics of the internals of the
watches so they could tell you about the
different movements and escapements and
why certain complications were harder to
pull off technically than others and so
it was a real Geeks blog and with that
technical hardcore writing developed
trust and so you and once you have the
trust of your readers
then you're able to extend Commerce in a
meaningful way and it's not asking them
to buy you know a microwave or some like
inexpensive or a throw pillow it's it's
it's saying we have your trust this is
what we believe to be a very important
you know watch or collectible and
because of that
um you know you're willing to pull the
trigger on a on a 20 30 50 000 purchase
so um it's trust is so essential do you
think that well I at the hustle we're
trying to we hired a bunch of riders
Sean hired some red as well for his
thing is a crypto thing and I I've
always debated this in my brain I'm like
do I hire good writers and teach them
about business or do I hire smart
business people and teach them how to
write
what did you find was the best way to do
that for uh watches yeah I mean the best
way to do that was to find people that
had the natural organic built-in love
for uh horology like just this decide
for for all things mechanical watches so
you know we would have writers that
um if you take for example like the
speed master though the the watch that
made it to the Moon from Omega
um you know they could tell you every
single variant and movement change and
the reasons why and they were just super
geeky on this stuff and they may have
been just like b-plus writers where you
get them but they had the technical
knowledge in their brain and that's a
lot easier to fix because you get them
to put that that technical information
out in draft form and then you just
apply an editorial layer over the top of
it where you have copy editors that come
in and help you know stitch together a
better more cohesive story before you
actually publish it out to the world
yeah I love that
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
you're a pretty chill guy when do you
get like really fired up like what what
gets you excited and or in a good or bad
way like um you know I get really
enthusiastic about the most random [__]
like the most uh it'll be like a
creative project that I'm like I bet I
could pull this off and I just go like I
just get too excited about it Sam has
that same thing but he also has it where
if he feels these wronged Sims like you
know willing to fight to the death about
it until he gets really pumped up what
gets you really pumped up rage is my
fuel I love I love fighting yeah so I
for me new ideas and working with
creative people is the the most kind of
like
um strongest source of fuel for me so
when I get together with an artist or a
fellow entrepreneur and I actually it
doesn't have to be someone that has
created something big it has it's rather
someone that just has wild ideas that
that are potentially
um
uh just new new ways of looking at the
world and so you meet a lot of
entrepreneurs that are opportunistic
iterative entrepreneurs where they'll
see something they'll say oh there's
some the rough edges on that particular
product I'm gonna go sand them down make
it easier for consumers and go launch a
business and they have great success I
like the ones that are just like really
thinking about
um entire new verticals or just flipping
something completely on its head in new
and creative ways
um so that is what I'm really drawn to
from just a straight idea a point of
view and so
entrepreneur-wise and when I invest in
some of these startups those are my
favorites are are those those crazy uh
more world-changing entrepreneurs um
in terms of the the rage side of things
um yeah dude you've had you've had a
bunch of Rage inducing moments I've
followed your career I've seen I've seen
you throw the [__] raccoon we saw
that one
I've seen people protest outside your
house I've seen you get in trouble for
like I don't know wanting to demolish
like a historical building I don't know
like the whole story but like you've had
you've kind of been a Target
yeah I mean those that those all have
their own unique story that the
historical building thing was definitely
not true that that was a that was a
pretty funny one in that um but but that
was uh that was just people wanting to
keep an old house up in the neighborhood
and they called it historically even
though it really wasn't
um uh we wanted to take it down because
it was filled with asbestos which we
didn't want to live in a house they had
asbestos in it but that's a whole other
story uh the rage stuff you know the the
the
the last four to five years of of my
life has been spent
um trying to to kind of Master my own
mind and and I I think that if you can't
um come to grips with your own Emperors
like personal peace of mind uh it's it's
a horrible place to be and so you know I
remember as a young entrepreneur just
kind of being on this 24 7 hustle to go
build build I gotta win I have to win I
have to win and it created a level of
anxiety that was not good for me and and
so I think that's probably why you saw
me kind of do things like the meditation
app and other other things because I it
was just a natural forcing function for
my my own self to like take some of that
stuff more seriously and so you know
um
I just want to be able to to be able to
sit and not have to have my mind be
always on and that that's kind of been
my goal and it's something I'm still I'm
still working on so that it's not like I
remember there was this interview with
Elon Musk and I'm not comparing myself
to Elon Musk but there's one thing that
I I can certainly relate to where he
talks about how his mind sometimes just
never shuts off and he's always thinking
about things problems new ideas like all
these things and
um and it's it's
uh for me it's always been
um that that has been not a blessing but
something that has just been has weighed
on me and and I've always tried to
um I guess the the big push in the last
few years has been to try and Wrangle
that
what kind of gets you all hot and
bothered now where you're thinking about
like the new Industries or the things
that excite you what what ideas would
you have one caveat that you're that
you're not currently pursuing so uh
because it's easy to say I'm excited
about this project I'm doing I think uh
like for example Palmer lucky was on the
last episode and he was talking about
all right we're like you're doing Andrew
you did Oculus what are the ideas that
are on your kind of like oh that's
interesting but like I only got one me
so I can't go do it because I think
that's that's the most interesting to
the audience
um and to into ourselves and that's
actually the origin of the podcast me
and Sam have more ideas than we have
time to do them and so we're like well
if we just say them out loud here maybe
people will take them and run with them
or or find something interesting in it
by the way have you ever talked to
Palmer Kevin that guy is wild
no I've never I've never chatted with
them I I have to go back and listen to
that episode though I'm really curious
to know I've I've seen some written
interviews but never never anything on
video form it went live yesterday it
sounds like you our YouTube and um most
of our listener ships on like podcast uh
feeds he is
he's something man that dude that guy's
eclectic he's just like enthusiastic
about everything he like knows a lot
about a lot he's like biology but more
um
but almost he's as smart but is more
common do you know what I mean like for
some reason I can relate to him even
though I know that he's just like so
much more smarter than I am
yeah I I had read some stuff and and I I
don't know how much of his true but some
of his his company stuff that he was
creating around drones for tracking
people and and some controversial
yeah I just it doesn't it doesn't fit
well with my ethos so I I haven't really
followed his careers as closely but um
I'd be curious to listen to the
interview for sure I think it was
probably it was probably our best guest
episode uh we've done a bunch of them
and and the reason why is he's like you
know he's like
um a he took pretty
genuine like he's pretty uh he's high
energy but he's like direct so it's like
um
you know why why do you do this or how
did you think about this and he's like
for example he's like I thought about
you know I'm kind of overweight could I
like solve obesity and he's like you
know but here's what doesn't work
telling me to eat less of foods that I
don't like the taste of and blah blah
and so he's like he's like my solution
was and I started prototyping this in my
house was to just instead of beyond meat
and stuff where they tried to make like
a burger out of chickpeas he's like I
wanted to just make fake food out of oil
zero calorie food that tastes amazing
because oil tastes amazing and we can
manipulate oil into anything we could
turn oil into candles we could turn it
into waxes we could turn it into this
into that he's like I created a grilled
cheese sandwich that was zero calorie
that tasted delicious using and we're
like dude that sounds kind of insane and
like he's like the pro we're like why
didn't you do this crazy idea you
sounded pretty passionate you went
pretty far he's like well there just
simply wasn't going to be enough oil
supply to do it and he's like we would
have had to take the oil out of the
sewage system and centrifuge it to the
recycling it he's like I and I realized
you know even I couldn't do that and I
was like wow this guy's like you know
half genius uh half crazy and I you know
I don't even know where the line is but
I find it fascinating that he a thinks
like this and B doesn't just think about
it you know literally he's like yeah in
my house we converted the dining room
into like this lab in order to like do
these you know these sorts of projects
and like you know out of one of them
came Andrew the eight billion dollar
company and the other one was gonna be
this crazy like you know oil-based fake
food
that's crazy that is awesome I love yeah
see that's the type of Entrepreneurship
that I'm I'm really drawn to it's just
like people that are hacking on stuff
um at night you know for me uh a lot of
the stuff that that I think about in
that that vein I tend to Outsource and
get other people to to work on it
um a lot of the stuff around
um longevity I've been interested in
specifically uh uh a drug uh called Rob
mycin where it's been proven now to
extend life and in in various animals
and now apply to dogs so myself and
um Jack Dorsey and Brian from coinbase
and a few others all have been putting
money into funding studies out of the
University of Washington
um to to Really prove this out in dogs
and canines and then eventually move it
into human trials so you know some of
that stuff and the biohacking stuff I
still put a lot of effort and time and
attention in and I I try this stuff out
on myself as well you know I'm I'm
trying some of these experimental things
um not because I I'm not one of these
people that wants to put you know young
people's blood in them and live forever
I I I want to die I just you know I I do
like the idea of not since I am an old I
am an older dad I didn't have my first
kid until my four until I was 40. I I
would like to be around a little bit
longer for them that's that's all well
I've heard of people doing this I know
Tim's doing this with the what's it
called silosylum uh like mushrooms
um yeah
and uh how much does it cost to fund a
study and what do you get out of it
other than like the altruistic of like
well we're just contributing to like the
grand thing but is there is there like a
direct outcome that you can get from it
like we can use this to fund a company
no no not not in this particular case
Yeah Tim was also uh put some money into
this one as well and there there was
there's nothing you get out of it other
than just trying to help further science
you know a lot of these
um in this particular case the study was
funded but be
depending on the sample size and how
many canines you have involved you can
only detect
um certain levels of of
um of output you need a larger sample
base uh it is called like a properly
powered study in order to detect smaller
little nuances in the data and so we
wanted to make sure it was powered
enough to detect I believe up to 10
lifespan increase and so to power it was
to add another million dollars or so
into the study
um to make sure that they could bring on
the additional canines required to make
that happen and you know I put my dog on
it as well and and he's
um 12 now and he still runs around like
a pup and and
um I attribute some of that to a cycle
of this that he did
um but yeah it's it's nothing other than
just like you you you're figuring out
ways in which you can like there's
there's all these different Avenues on
the philanthropic side where you're like
what what is Meaningful to me personally
and um uh this this this particular
study you know I think even if it just
worked for dogs would be fantastic like
forget humans if if I could have my dog
live for an additional five years like
what a win you know so that it was kind
of a win-win study dude I I talked to
this guy that was like building I think
it was called
is it called a ageless RX I forget his
the name of his company but he was he's
trying to like you know do longevity
stuff uh supplements and [__] like that
and uh things are going well for him but
I was he was kind of explaining his
reasoning he was like you know a lot of
people are afraid to take these
medicines but we've been thinking
if we told them it's good for their dog
they're actually will give it to their
dog and he was he was kind of like
hypothesizing to me and like
brainstorming with me in real time he
was like maybe we should just like do
this for dogs and just give it to dogs
and if once people see that it makes
their dog live longer then they'll be
like yeah yeah you know [__] it give me
that pill I'll take that thing uh
because there's there's so much easier
to commence to give it to their dog I'm
with Kevin oh for sure
dogs live forever
well genome-wise there's so much more
overlap and and and and connection there
between canines and humans and there is
a lot of other animals out there so
um but you know the back to your
question though about
um you know out of curiosity what what
would I go pursue right now in terms of
startups that I'm not doing
um I believe and it's very very clear
now that AI in the next five years is
gonna change everything
um we're seeing open Ai and a lot of the
projects they put out there recently
um whether it be creative writing or I
believe Fiverr as a company it will just
be non-existent
um it's going to destroy the low end of
the creative Market initially and then
work its way up the chain and you know
just the the outputs that you're getting
now from prompt based art
um you know the future versions of
Photoshop are are not going to be about
moving uh Mouse and pixels around it's
just going to be telling the computer
what to do on your behalf you know
you'll highlight an area and say you
know change this aspect and and it'll
all be done via prompt and and meaning
you type in what you want to see change
and the AOL we'll just make it happen
we're seeing that today and I'm seeing
you know advancements on the a side in
in medicine uh obviously all the
creative side there's a probably a half
dozen or so tools now that will complete
uh you know write complete paragraphs
for you if you're writing sci-fi you
give it some initial kind of prompts of
where you want the story to go and the
writing is quite good I I have no doubt
in the next five years we'll see a New
York Times bestseller that was 90
written by AI so it's it's I I there's
just so much interest in with the
interest and excitement flows the
engineering Talent so I've seen a lot of
um friends that are these you know a lot
of people I worked with at Google and
and other places where you know they're
they're very insanely amazing Engineers
you know previously working on
distribution systems and some of these
hard problems that they were trying to
solve and now said hey I'm I'm actually
going to Pivot into this this new world
of AI and anytime you watch that kind of
flow of high quality engineering Talent
go move into something you you pay
attention so I'm looking for at a lot of
investments in that particular sector
um and I'm very bullish on it and
something I don't have time to work on
but I believe some great businesses are
going to be built there
what would be an application you would
want to do in that space of all those
kind of like threads where it's like
creative work medicine
um you know writing an AI book is there
an application that you can think of
that you're like I feel like AI can
solve this because I think that's that's
it's a hammer in search of nails at this
point uh that's when I talk Sean you
made a joke you made a joke I I always
teased Sean about web3 because I'm not
the biggest fan of it and he was and we
were joking about how uh he was like
coming up with ideas with AI he's like
finally a use case we found it and like
with AI it seems like there's actually
way more obvious use cases right but uh
yeah what what application excites you
oh I'd love to have that web 3 debate at
some point too but um on the AI side you
know it we're already seeing this right
so so figma was purchased by Adobe you
probably all saw that it was crazy
acquisition
um you know probably that the the the
the the standard these days for
prototyping and and creating interfaces
for everything from mobile apps to
websites to to you name it
um we're seeing uh already built-in
plugins to figma that allow you to
prompt based build uh anything in in
just a matter of seconds so you can say
hey give me an interface for a mobile
app that has these five options uh in
this color with this futuristic type
style and you know you get something
back in real time in in in 25 seconds
and it's it's rough but it's giving my
design team and other designers out
there
um just a great starting point and it
saves them a ton of time and effort but
this is like inning one like two three
years from now it'll be doing 90 of the
work versus you know the first right now
with probably 20 of the work so
um that is is is super exciting and the
assistance and and time to market for
new ideas new projects I think is going
to be compressed even further it's it's
the same thing that we what happened
with the kind of like late web 2 when we
went from racking our own servers to
fully deployed in an automated managed
you know AWS instances that in some of
these databases that just Auto scaled as
you threw traffic at it it really
compressed the time to the go to market
time you know uh by quite a bit I think
we'll see the same thing on on the
design side so the speed at which we can
develop uh and deploy new ideas is just
going to be uh you know probably uh in
order to order magnitude better than it
is today
um so I'm excited for that where do you
uh a question that we started asking
people and it's actually uh I've always
learned so much from this but what
message boards or Facebook groups or
websites uh what corners of the web are
you lurking in right now like for me I I
love Facebook groups there's always like
a weird Facebook group like a tiny
example is over Landing do you guys know
what over Landing is it's like no it's
like um I don't know the exact
definition but it's like you know how
you see like Toyota 4Runners or F-150s
that have like campers on it and it
looks like they can go in the desert for
like two weeks so I started like joining
over Landing groups like three years ago
because I was like oh this is kind of an
interesting turn that's picking up or
another one that we got really into a
couple years ago was Mobility so like
all these grown men not caring about
yoga but they called it mobility and it
was all about like stretching and it's
like what's going on with there's like
all these weird Instagram guys like
doing all this stretching [__] it's kind
of intriguing and like a lot of times
it's like instead of instead of therapy
Executive coaching uh you know yeah yeah
that's what happened from uh from yoga
to Mobility yeah they just changed like
mayo naoli and uh it totally worked it's
awesome like I love Mobility now and
like for example for the body stuff Tim
Ferriss was always pretty good at that
like he'd be talking about all this
weird stuff like fasting it's like dude
what the hell is this fasting thing what
are you talking about uh and uh that was
like a really cool corner of the web to
like look in on and like see like how
are the Geeks behaving now so I can
learn like how the rest of the normal
like Average Joe is going to care about
in the next five or ten years yeah where
is it Chris Dixon quote are you familiar
with it yeah
this is what the Geeks Who are playing
with on the weekends will become like
what we're all using like if several
years later it's something some version
of that yeah so like what geeky places
are you hanging out right now for for
Shawna Knights like a lot of Twitter
people so we'll find like specific
people in Twitter who are like quirky
and we're like what the hell is this guy
talking he's talking crazy I mean it's
really cool yeah I mean I I follow a ton
of people in in crypto Twitter so I pay
attention to all the on you know the
what's happening on web3 via VIA
um Twitter and then also you know mostly
Discord it's just a lot of private
discords it's a lot of private telegrams
small groups and Gatherings of peers
they get together discuss new ideas new
projects
um these Dows uh these uh decentralized
autonomous organizations where people
get together to discuss and collect and
purchase things
um so it it's a lot of I I've never
spent so much time in Discord it's like
it's crazy that the conversation has
shifted there in in Twitter largely
um dude I hate that by the way I love
the fact that like I dig or read it or
something exists where you can just like
if you Googled it and found it like you
could participate now I'm like oh what
the [__] man Kevin's probably got this
crazy ass telegram group that like
there's I don't even I can't get in
because I don't even know exists no you
can join proof it's fifty thousand
dollars and you're in bro it's easy
no it's I think it's more like
it's
people realize that
um
they wanted a little bit more intimate
conversation so I have a feeling that
like there was a there was a lot of of
this move to do smaller private discords
and smaller telegram groups because it
would lead to just not the masses
flooding in and the chaos that you would
see on Reddit and so I that's kind of
been the move that that I've seen in in
the Dr the reason behind a lot of that
but
um it's not hard to get into you just
have to actually show them that you you
know what you're doing like you have to
you know get in there and embrace web3
which it sounds like Sam you may not be
the biggest fan of but you have to you
have to get in there and and and and
talk the talk and know where to go and
people will tell you like this is the
place to be hanging out or I'm enjoying
this Discord over here and you'll learn
about this and this is where the AI
discords are or whatever it may be and
um that's just kind of the new it's the
new Facebook Facebook's uh it's it's
it's I'm sure it's good for some things
but it's it's dead when it comes to web
three you want me to tell you my why I'm
not a fan of this and yes please I'm
gonna get you I'm gonna try and get you
fired up here and then yeah let's try
talk about proof I do it sounds like I'm
making an easy out which I kind of am
but basically like I am I'm I'm decently
educated just by hanging out with Sean
and so I have to admit that like some of
my beliefs are a little bit loosely held
uh and and I'm not the most educated on
the topic but my opinion on web3 is
basically it's a bunch of like it's just
this kind of circular economy of a bunch
of people making
making products to serve an industry
that has yet to like truly figure out or
I don't know what you call an industry a
movement that has yet to truly figure
out like what the what the thing is that
they're doing and there's so many
examples where people I think are fairly
like egotistical and elitists about it
saying like
Web 2.0 is old and like the way this has
to be decentralized or this has to be
that's why it's like man just because
you're putting web 3 in front of
something that doesn't mean that there's
actually a problem here and I think
you're just wasting so much time and
energy working on something that is just
like a circle jerk that doesn't actually
solve a problem better than the web
Point Web 2.0 version also I thought
it's pretty dogmatic where it's like
decentralize everything it's like dude I
want some stuff centralized like can you
imagine like calling customer service on
a decentral like it's like no I like
there are some things that I want like
to have a to be centralized and I
thought that they're a little bit too
dogmatic and I thought that they were
oftentimes I'm saying like they like you
people uh like you guys like didn't
always have wonderful Solutions you were
just making [__] up in order to like get
in the game and I just thought that it
it kind of bothered me
yeah I mean I I feel your frustration
there and that I too am someone that
um when I look at what's being built in
web 3 if it's it's just for the sake of
calling something decentralized and
there's nothing behind it or no
structural Advantage for that being the
case
um I think it's it's it's it's silly you
know it's like I'll give you a great
example
um we're we're working on
um there's a lot of things that you want
to do in web3 some of them are high
value and some of them are low value
when you were talking about working with
the community so we have a community of
people that come together to do all
different types of things and some of it
is what we call token gated content so
it's like a membership model where you
have to be a member of something or hold
a certain nft in order to unlock certain
access to videos or content or whatever
it may be some of those things can be
high value uh items where you receive an
nft or something that is um actually has
some Financial like you know something
behind it that is a case where you want
to actually have that Hardware wallet
and pull it out and and do it in a way
that is secure and that is protected and
um but the rest of the time you don't
need that you can use a Google login
it's okay to use a web 2 login it's okay
to use your email and password with
two-factor authentication like we don't
have to throw away a lot of the
Fantastic technology that's been built
in web 2. there's other things like for
example some decentralized uh
maximalists and I think maximalist is
really what we're talking about here
because anyone that is a maximalist uh
on uh this means what you just like
extreme it just means that you are so
into something that you can't see any
other way and it's like it's your way or
there's no possible there are people out
there that say there is no other
cryptocurrency than Bitcoin that's the
only one
pumps are our Buddy isn't pop like don't
they call them online a Bitcoin Maxi I
don't think he I think he is a maximum
coin and and you know dorsey's in that
camp too where he's like trying to
extend Bitcoin and says that's that's
kind of the only currency and I I think
this applies to so many different things
like I don't want to get into Political
talk but anytime you get to the fringes
of anything where it's like this is the
only thing that matters you get into
Crazy Town in my point of view and so
you know I think that is a danger of web
3 where there's a lot of that kind of
idea that if if it's not pure web 3 it's
not right and I'm with you I 100 agree
but that said like I've seen this idea
and a lot of the defy tooling when I say
defy I mean decentralized finance a lot
of the D5 tooling that's being built on
the blockchain uh in a performant way in
a cost-effective way in a way that when
you think about Wells Fargo as an
organization with you know 150 000
employees I'm just making that up by
maybe it's fifty thousand or seventy
five thousand somewhere in between that
that range where that is just a lot of
bloat and in because of that bloat and
because of that in insane monthly not
that that company has to cover
um you know those dollars are are not
not flowing to the right people and so
there are examples of more efficient
ways of doing Finance on the blockchain
that that can be done in a trustless way
written into smart contract code that
will mean for better outcomes for the
consumer now those can be paired with
centralized Solutions right like
coinbase is a centralized organization
you have a email address you can send it
if something is wrong with your crypto
account but they hold and keep
decentralized currency right and they
and they do things like decentralized
staking where you earn four percent on
your ethereum but they're a centralized
company that gives you that customer
support so I'm not I'm I'm a I think
that the the ones that really win here
yes there are going to be the people
that say self-custody is the only way
there's this famous saying that if it's
not your keys it's not your crypto like
like you have to hold your own private
keys I'm not in that camp I do that
personally and use safety deposit box
and a whole slew of things to safeguard
that for some things but there's other
Solutions where where a hybrid approach
makes more sense so know that your
argument is completely valid and that a
lot of entrepreneurs that are building a
web 3 completely agree with you and that
let's not throw away the baby with the
bath water here there's a lot of great
things but there are also some great
advantage is that come with being
decentralized or a whole slew of other
Technologies that's being built on web3
um that that I could point to that you'd
say like oh that yeah actually that that
does make more sense than the old way of
doing things so let's let's do this real
quick so you've probably seen just like
anybody else these like uh there's like
these permanent uh like just like
there's permeables for crypto there's
Perma bears and their mission in life is
to basically find every stupid use case
of crypto and highlight it or every bad
investment or every sure clip of a a pro
you know some dude at a16z who goes on a
podcast and says something dumb about
crypto when asked about a use case
um and you talked about me because I was
just on their podcast two weeks ago so
no no they I haven't seen
you but Dixon but like you know there's
there's people that sort of are are
focused on on poking holes and I think
there's some value in poking holes but
there's also you know it's a little bit
embarrassing to spend your whole day
poking holes on something you know but
let's put it this way I'm on this
podcast I'm the the crypto believer I'm
the one who puts a significant portion
of my net worth I have a crypto Media
company I have a bunch of belief in
crypto but for this use kit for this
exercise here I'm gonna
point out two things that I think uh all
would be would be you know strong and
valid points against crypto to somebody
like you who is also a crypto believer
so I want you to kind of argue against
these and I hope that uh this doesn't
get clipped as like you know famous
investor X fumbles the ball uh when
trying to explain you know crypto thing
so let's try to do better than that yeah
let's do it okay so the first would be
around uh nfts right so you're a big nft
guy and there's nft art which I think
pretty hard to argue against at this
point like digital art cool their
ability to own digital art that's one
use case for nfts but a lot of people
who believe in nfts will also say
but that's just the beginning and if
Jesus is a file format it's a protocol
there's all these different use cases
for nfts and um I saw the founder of of
openc I think uh talked about this
yesterday on a podcast where he's like
they're like why he you know he's like
oh in other use cases NFC tickets and
they're like so why would there why
would you want to have an nft ticket
he's like well because then you it's you
know you could plug it into defy and you
could take a loan against your ticket
and then people were like why the [__]
would I want to take a loan against my
60 like concert ticket like is that
right really what the hype is about and
it's sort of a silly use case so I would
like you to give me the non-silly nft
use cases that you're excited about so
like yeah and the well let's let's take
an example
let's take the ticket example and and
the art one is easy it's a new canvas
but let's actually let's cover that
first the art one is easy it's a new
canvas you can do things and pull from
uh real-time data to display our in very
unique fun creative ways right like it's
really not that much different than your
than Rolexes I mean like there's no
reason why a Rolex is 150 000 other than
like a lot of people think it's cool so
yeah
I would say there's a difference there
because it's something you may not know
about Rolex is they make over a million
Rolexes per year and so Rolex it hides
that number and the reason they hide
that number is because if they didn't
have a sense of scarcity around it and
they they do this specifically when you
go in their stores they'll always be
next time you walk by an actual true
Rolex boutique notice how there's like
some missing spots and and when you go
inside and that's all play it's play
because they're like oh they're sold out
they're not available but we can put you
on this list and in in three to four
months we might you might get a phone
call guess what you always get the phone
call and and the watch is coming because
there's they're making a million a year
the nice thing about you know the the
one of the things that I was always so
confused by is I was a common comic book
collector way back in the day and I
bought Wolverine number one because I
love Wolverine it was like my childhood
like I always wanted to own one right
and so I bought Wolverine number one and
it always hovered around fifty dollars
and I was like why is this not going up
it's a very first Wolverine launched in
the 80s right it wasn't the first
appearance of Wolverine but it was the
first Wolverine Comic and I finally got
a hold of a really well-known collector
and he goes oh he goes you don't know
they knew by that point that Wolverine
was a hot character and so they printed
over 300 000 copies of that first
edition I was like oh [__] like that's
why there's just a flood of these in the
market so you know nfts the beautiful
thing about this when you have an artist
produce a piece it has proven provenance
so you know where it's come from has
proven scarcity so you can't like create
you know additional add-ons or
duplicates because it's all recorded on
the blockchain and then you have the
unique ability to do very creative
things like animation uh oracles work
the art can change based on the stock
market price or time of day or phase of
the moon and there's just so much more
extension it's a new vertical for art
fine that's great awesome like digital
frames are going to be getting better it
is going to be a thing like there's no
in my mind there is no argument to be
had there that this won't be because I
don't that against the the future or the
inevitable and art is the easy use case
for nfts the ticket thing is different
right so the ticket thing I I I'm with
you like I understand that people are in
in web 3
are trying to like create these fancy
financial instruments to like Leverage
you on anything that you own they're
like hey you have a ticket to that
upcoming concert that's sold out you
know spin into this defy unit and take a
loan against it and then you can buy it
back and use the money in the short term
and it's like that's all [__] man
that nobody's gonna do that right it's
it's it's don't get me wrong there's
there's there are specific use cases
where that does make sense like loan
against nfts is going to be the same
thing that happens when Christie's gives
you a loan against your Picasso right
like these these happen this happens all
the time it's just a parallel for the
digital world there are certain types of
of assets digital assets that getting
loans against them if it's something you
want will make sense the tickets thing
for me is very confusing but while I
will tell you is interesting and I've
talked to actual rock stars about this
like I had Mike Shinoda from Linkin Park
on my show and he's a huge nft fan and
he creates them and
um you know awesome awesome Flex by the
way you know I've I've talked to some
rock stars about this
that's cool I think it's cool I think
it's important because like you you want
to get the artist to buy in on this
totally too because it just keeps saying
it's cool yeah yeah he's a he's an
awesome guy very approachable very
approachable in the terms of rock star
guys but Noah will tell you that like
well what we talked about which is an
obvious one is like okay imagine the
tickets well let me step back one thing
I believe to be true 90 plus percent of
people that interact with nfts over the
long term I believe won't even know it
as they're doing it as an nft it'll just
be something where they have a digital
wallet an app or something like that and
they have a ticket there right they're
not going to know that behind the scenes
that is powered by the blockchain and
recorded by the blockchain right so I
think what's gonna happen is
the nice thing about the blockchain is
because it is a ledger in an immutable
Ledger that is that is a way to say
improve that you have done something
that you either attended an event or
you've you know you've actually
physically done something there's a ton
of possibilities that I can unlock right
if I go and I see Mike Shinoda play five
shows or ten shows maybe he says okay
now according to the blockchain in our
app and again the consumer doesn't need
to know about this anyone that's
attended 10 of my shows gets a VIP meet
and greet before the show right and
there's a thousand different things that
you can do that you want to have that
security of the blockchain behind the
scenes so it's not being forged so
there's not being copies of it being
made so there's not like a way to fake
it and that's the nice thing about the
blockchain is it provides you a way to
have the security and knowledge that
something is not being faked and you can
imagine that's broadly applicable to a
whole slew of different Industries
um I don't think we'll be calling them
quote unquote nfts you know it's just
going to be a great piece of tech it's
just another database that's all it is
it's a distributed
um immutable database that is
decentralized it's that's all this is
which unlocks a bunch of fun new use
cases let's caveat it all right so let's
say because I think I get when I get
what you're saying but I also get the uh
the eye rolls that people get when it's
like cool tell me like how this is going
to make my life better and it's like
well the cool thing about a blockchain
is that it's provable scarce it's like
it's like what you're telling me about
the Under the Hood part whereas for
example if my mom is like if I'm like
Mom you should set up an email address
and she's like what the heck is email I
don't need that and it's like well no
check this out like you know you send
letters or you you know you send letters
to your sister who lives across the
country like watch this if you do it
this way it's free and it'll be instant
and like oh wow that's cool and hey you
know it's even better because it's all
digital you can just type the word and
it'll find that file you don't have to
keep it organized somewhere in a folder
in your house yeah all right so I can I
don't have to tell her how it works at
all I can literally just say it made
your life better by being by giving you
you know more time More Money More
whatever and so I think the question is
what does nfts give what what does what
will an nft give a person that makes
their life better without explaining how
how the tech works at all sure I'll give
you I'll give you a great example of one
that hasn't launched yet but something
that that I'm personally working on
so I I I'm working with
um a well-known like very culty kind of
wine producer out there and
um you know wine at the highest level at
the high end it's a tricky it's a tricky
business because there's you know
forgeries there's fake labels there's
they're putting holograms on the side of
them they're putting
um chips inside of the labels so that
they can be scanned to to prove that
they're authentic right
um that's one piece so the first
question is if I'm buying off the
secondary market and not directly from
the producer am I getting something
that's legit excuse me the second piece
of that is once I received that bottle
you know how do I store it to ensure
that if I'm going to keep something and
I want this asset to appreciate over
time
um and I want to drink it a decade from
now or two then you know how do I ensure
that it is being stored the right way so
one thing that is happening in the next
four months will be the issuance of nfts
to people that is going to be from a
major well-known Winery where it will
represent one physical bottle of wine
there's a couple advantages here one you
don't have to take possession of it
right away you can let it sit in its
proven perfect storage conditions and
age for decades to come you can let it
appreciate in that in those storage
conditions and you can hold on to the
proven ownership of it as an nft let's
say that bottle of wine for four or five
x's over the next decade you don't ever
have to then pull the wine in out of the
cellar take ownership above it find a
third party to sell it and then resell
it where that person is questioning the
authenticity of that wine instead you
can just transfer that nft to a buddy
you can gift it to them for a special
occasion or an anniversary and then when
they decided hey I want to drink this
they press two buttons and that bottle
of wine that has been stored perfectly
for a decade shows up at their door that
is efficiency that eliminates fraud
there is just so much to love in that
equation and that'll be applied to the
watch industry to the luxury world to
all these different verticals and it
just makes sense like what about that
I'm just curious as you hear me explain
it it doesn't sound like a better world
like in in terms of fixing a bunch of
problems
I think uh if I was gonna
if I was going to argue against that
like just a steel man the argumentation
I think it would be
cool uh like maybe it's gonna maybe
these are certificates for Collectibles
most you know it's not gonna that
doesn't impact most people's lives
because most people are not collecting
high-end bags or wines or this where
there's huge problems of forgery like
that uh that may be one thing which is
it's not going to impact that many
people
um in that sense oh you're telling me
and if he's at this game-changing world
changing technology but that's a really
Niche specific you know one percenter
type problem and then the other is like
you know
um sounds like an nft is like a digital
certificate
um you know you could have done that
with it with another type of certificate
but
um or another type of database maybe and
but maybe this is better uh like I do
agree it's better but like it was
possible before it didn't take the
impossible make it possible it made the
uh the possible made it maybe made it
more efficient or a little bit more
convenient for the consumer and so I
think that would be maybe one argument
against it but I don't want to go too
far in the weeds yeah the other thing
that I think that to add on to that
though is that because you have well
I'll give you an example like back
and you know the back to the rock star
example of an artist
um you're Reliant upon if you did want
to do some type of Rewards program or
something for well actually let me step
up one more point the point you made
about the one percenter problem and is
this applicable to those people you're
absolutely right like there's only a
certain number of people that are going
to collect art at the highest level and
one at the highest level and all that I
mean granted these are double digit
billions of dollars of year like big
markets to go after but you're right
these specific use cases that I'm giving
are are very Niche right
um I think on the more broadly uh on on
the on the idea of just membership and
access and prove where you've been what
you've done to unlock loyalty and
rewards over the long term and think
about you know replacing the AmEx points
or you know other point type systems or
reward systems with blockchain the
beautiful thing about it being
decentralized and this is one argument
for decentralization is that it's
forever on the chain and you're not
dependent upon a company being around
for that for that to exist so if an
artist is engaged with a startup that is
working on a Loyalty Rewards program for
them and they run out of capital and die
three years later as long as they stored
their information on the blockchain that
artists can then just pick up where they
left off and it just it continues
forward and we've already seen this
happen where there's been several
startups that have stored their
information on the blockchain where they
go out of business because they just
their their idea didn't hit and then
someone fills the the void and comes and
says I have a better take on this and
now let me tap into that public data and
use it going forward so that not All Is
Lost which is kind of a A New Concept in
rather than just a database going away
it's always going to be there and can be
reused which I think is pretty pretty
compelling the really simple two-second
example of this is you play a game you
you get really into fortnite you go buy
a bunch of skins you you dress up your
character you got the cool you know like
glider and you bought all that stuff and
you know a year and a half goes by your
friends have moved on they're all
playing Call of Duty now you've sank 350
dollars into fortnite you don't own
those items you can't resell those items
you can't recoup any of that value nor
could you take those items into any
other game so in a web 3 world either
another game could come out that says
hey we accept item we we plugged into
this protocol so you can bring your cool
sword from game one to game two that
makes the sword more valuable because
now it can be used in multiple games so
maybe we're seeing this already the
interoperability between multiple web3
platforms saying that this is a defined
standard and now these items can
digitally move between platforms it
makes a ton of sense now those items are
more valuable because they can be used
in more places and the other one is that
if I'm just done with the game I could
just dump it on to the next person who's
really interested in fortnite and I can
recoup some of my investment which will
make more people want to spend in games
because it's not just a mighty pit it's
an asset that they could resell all
right so that's like the quicker example
maybe I love that you joined my side is
on your side but I have to argue the
other way uh in order for this to be
interesting yeah at the end you're like
I get it I'm in there's another crypto
nerd argument would be okay for years
people have been saying that Bitcoin is
this this inflation head or this
currency that that's that's uh that
doesn't inflate and oh my God you know
how lucky for you guys the US government
starts printing trillions of dollars
inflation is at record highs it's in the
news every day
wait what happened to that awesome
inflation hedge ask them why is it down
50 when inflation is is is is the bigger
problem than ever shouldn't this be
shouldn't this be your time to shine
Bitcoin so yeah what say you to that
yeah I mean it's it's a real shame that
that Bitcoin has been so spiky because
if it hadn't been this linear growth to
20 000 to where it is today we'd all be
like this is the most amazing thing ever
like like if you just take the spikes
out and make it look linear it it still
looks like an incredible asset like you
know just go back five years look where
it is now versus five years ago so it's
the spiky nature of it that that that
hurts it in the end I would say that um
you know I I'm a fan I think Bitcoin is
is a tough one because it's I I don't
like that it's not a green currency and
I don't see a clear path ever being the
case
um and I know everyone's trying to
extend it in new and exciting ways and
try to make it more ethereum-like and so
that it can do more than just be uh this
type of digital gold
um for me you know when I when I think
about those types of assets
it's I'm responsible in that I I'm not
betting the farm on this but is it a
small percentage of my portfolio
absolutely and I just considered another
asset class that provides me a little
bit of
um of diversification across the board
so you know the majority of of my you
know personal Holdings is is still
um standard you know index funds uh that
that are pretty vanilla the low-cost
index funds you know the Vanguard Way
right yeah and I was actually going to
ask that what what is your liquid
portfolio look like like where like I
was at I was been waiting to ask you
that Sam is like a ETF low-cost ETFs and
bonds dude I'm 80 in Vanguard index
funds 20 bonds that's all and then I
build private businesses yes Sean like
has put everything into I'm like
investing crypto and then like you know
five companies I believe in and you know
a little bit of index funds like it's
like yeah zero like it's like five
percent or something like that I keep
ten percent in cash or something and so
what would your or what would your pie
chart look like and obviously it changes
over time yeah so so my pie chart would
be essentially this
um you know 80 percent well I think
there's an important thing to caveat
here is that as a venture capital uh
partner over true Ventures I have a lot
of
um risk on the table there in in Venture
early stage Investments did you have to
put your own money into that or is that
just your character I do yeah I had to
put my own money into it as an investing
partner you also invest alongside the
fund so
um that is my bucket of risk right so
just setting that aside and saying okay
you know I have carrying the fund that's
my pocket of high high risk too much
capitalism right you put like I don't
know what like quarter million dollars
or a million dollars or something like
that into that it depends on the size of
the fund it's it's a it's it's a
percentage of the fund we just closed
our latest fund which is 750 million and
so the partners put in a percent of of
that
um in back into the fund uh I'd have to
look at what the exact numbers are but
it's it's substantial they want you to
have skin in the game when you're
investing
um so you know I consider that to be
like those are those are the big high
risk buckets so everything else I do I
want to be just super vanilla and it's
it's that it's that Vanguard index fund
um keep it you know keep it really
simple I don't do bond funds I'd rather
rely on people to buy Bonds on my behalf
um you know I am laddering into uh uh
bills right now because you're getting
four plus percent in the short term and
so you know just just Ladder into to to
those makes a ton of sense right now
um you know anyone out there that has 10
grand that's sitting round that doesn't
go by an eye bill right now that's
earning over nine percent is just insane
like that's the most no-brainer scenario
for for someone that's listening to this
podcast by the way there's like one week
left of that right I was like yeah
that's right obviously not investment
advice but you are getting the full
faith of the US government as the backer
and it's over nine percent and you can
do ten thousand for yourself and ten
thousand for your spouse which is uh
amazing so
um anyway it's I keep it really simple
and then and then the rest is is is the
crypto the crypto side of things is like
you know let's call it uh 50 nfts and 50
uh digital assets and that's you know
probably ten percent overall okay
so so 90 of
non-venture stuff is in just an index
fund
yeah yeah in multiple index funds that
cover a variety of markets but yeah do
you touch real estate at all or no
not really other than just you know my
own stuff do you own or rent
I own
uh we're we've always had this debate
and I know you got to go to them and I
hear your alarms going off but we always
have this debate well we both agree I I
own I wish I would have rented dude I
just want to rent everything I don't
want to own a lot of stuff do you regret
owning or or do you like being an owner
um you know the the thing is when
interest rates were low you can just
take a bunch of capital back out of your
house and pour it back into the market
assuming that you're going to beat that
you know if you could get uh own a house
uh
take a loan out against against that
house and get you know a two a couple
couple of points and and earn five to
seven in the market like I'll take that
Delta all day long so
um that's kind of the way I play it
cool well dude you're uh I'm really
happy we got to talk I um I used to work
out of the Reddit building at uh third
in Bryant and I remember seeing you walk
by and I was like oh [__] that's Kevin I
wish I would have said hey that was in
2012. so it's only been 11 years later
10 years later but uh I'm happy that we
were able to talk
um I've been a big fan of yours I know
Sean has as well so it's really uh
exciting to be able to meet you I love
that you guys are doing this show I mean
it reminds me a lot of like the the kind
of fun little hash out debates that Tim
Ferriss and I have when we do our random
shows like they're just fun right you
gave a couple of friends together and
shoot the [__] and some some crazy
discussions uh it could come out of it
so that's that's great dude those were I
can't believe how big those were back
then I remember the the Kevin and Tim
shows I think they call that he like had
a funny name for you like Tim Tim top
yeah oh I call him Tim Tim still and it
is Kev Kev but yeah we just shot one
here uh in person uh maybe two weeks ago
which was fun it was good to see Tim
again I hadn't seen him in in a minute
but uh little things you like I remember
you talked about Wim Hof back been and I
was like oh and that you know next day
I'm on my floor like breathing
everything yeah on purpose
you're gonna remember your wife Dr Dara
is that her name Daria yeah Daria like
it's funny it's like that stuff was so I
mean it still is but it was like
particularly when I was in 22 and just
getting into Silicon Valley like I
really looked up to you guys I was like
just show me how to Silicon Valley you
know what I mean it was really cool
yeah that was that was a fun I was I I
miss not living in the same city as as
Tim because we we always have get into
some trouble when we're together so yeah
you guys thanks for doing the blueprint
for us in in terms of like hey if you
could find somebody you got chemistry
with and you shoot the [__] and like
what's your content your content is just
yo I'm super curious and interested in a
bunch of things and this becomes my
outlet to summarize you know my set of
experiments and rabbit holes I've been
going down and like you know we would
have never done a podcast of like oh the
ad Revenue will be enough it's like no
it's not really like [__] that it's not
really relevant
um and we're seeing you know Tim and you
and how oh actually it's these
relationships and these Investments and
there's these little side projects you
kick up and actually you can make this
whole thing work without having to go
you know do this like you know
traditional kind of venture path of uh
yeah of raising money to go do this
thing so that was pretty uh inspiring so
yo thank you for that I think you know
just seeing a blueprint is like that
Roger Bannister four minute mile where
you're like oh I can have the lifestyle
I want but on my terms and yeah if these
guys can do it then we can do it oh I
mean it's it's congrats to you both it
seems like uh from from what I heard
here at the beginning of this episode
you guys have done quite well and and uh
congrats on your success it's awesome
congrats to you too and thanks for kind
of Paving the way we appreciate it and
thanks for coming thanks for having me
[Music]